are you a happy person now you have
children you have a relationship i've
read you're
you're with a man yeah um christmas is
everything
in your world perfect or do you want me
to help you with some problems
if you want me to help you get out of uh
whatever situation you're in
how much time do we have um
well look besides the fact that we are
in where we are and
and it's you know hard to not
feel so much of the [ __ ] and struggle
that's going on
right in my home i'm very uh
i'm very lucky about having these
two babies and my husband and they make
it all
better it's changed my life um
is it possible to be a good mother and
be an actress at the same time
balancing the you know kids and a career
like yours
is it possible to be fully present when
you've got all of that going on in your
head
well right now i'm not going to an
actual set but because of all this
stuff you know i'm i'm not as present as
i would like
to be and it's really hard um
because i'm always like convinced
they're going to like forget who i am if
i'm gone for like a day
you know i have looked at my children
like i am your mother i'm your mother
um i am nervous about like actually
leaving and
and going to work when that happens uh
because there's something really nice
about just being home with them all the
time but
they're really young right now so i feel
like i have
that as an advantage they don't really
know when i'm not there
uh but that time is coming and i'm gonna
do my best to balance
and they will come first